tf1 à 20 heures avec roger gicquel des
vents de plus de 100 km/heure sur la
manche aujourd'hui en principe accalmie
dans les prochaines heures
l' affaire des otages du polisario c'est
le dialogue mais côté français un ton
très ferme
nouveau témoignage sur le cambodge des
khmers rouges celui des médecins sans
frontières vendanges 77 beaucoup de
sucre dans le vin pour compenser le
manque de soleil
bonsoir je suis un fidèle auditeur de
bison futé d'ailleurs c'est inévitable
chaque fois que j'ouvre mon transistor
où ma télévision
il est là bien tranquille sécurisant à
l'ecoute des grandes transhumances
il me dit quand ça s'est plutôt mal
passé sur les routes
il compte les bouchons en tirant sur son
cas lui mais il hoche la tête
il regarde dans la direction du grand
manitou et il dit en souriant que si ça
a été mal pour l'aller ce sera pire pour
le retour il nous reste juste un peu de
temps entre la hantise des départs et l'
angoisse de revenir pour profiter de ce
long et du week-end en france quand la
météo s'en mêle bison futé a un peu de
vent dans les plumes ça va glisser ça va
déraper le vent va nous déporter la
pluie va nous noyer le mieux croyez moi
comme me l'a dit bison futé c'est ou de
ne pas rentrer du tout rester en
week-end toute la semaine
ou alors rentrer tout de suite
maintenant pendant qu'il est encore
temps
entre les deux la moyenne pour les
retours c'est entre demain 15 heures
dernier délai et jeudi matin juste avant
l'école nous allons voir dans un instant
les vrais derniers conseils de bison
futé mais auparavant le point sur la
météo avec cette tempête qui nous a
inquiété aujourd'hui et la provoc et
même une tragédie en mer au large des
côtes espagnoles jean pire à bout
oui ne très forte tempête avec des
rafales de vents soufflant jusqu'à 120
km heure s'est propagée toute la nuit
dernière et une grande partie de la
matinée sur les côtes de la manche la
mer du nord et le golfe de gascogne
cette tempête a provoqué le naufrage
d'un cargo grec le tina à 300 milles au
large de la rochelle
malheureusement dix marins ont trouvé la
mort et cinq autres ont pu être sauvées
si ce conflit sera sept navires pour
fuir
actuellement les rochers au large de
lannion dans les côtes du nord c'est un
voilier avec quatre personnes à bord qui
a disparu à l'hélicoptère et des
vedettes de sauvetage ont entrepris des
recherches actuellement le vent n'est
plus que de force 7
c'est à dire environ 70 kilomètres heure
la météo prévoit que cette tempête doit
s'arrêter dans la nuit demain matin une
zone de pluie intéressera l'est de la
france elle s'évacuera en cours de
journée vers la suisse et l'allemagne
l'après-midi un temps variable avec
soleil et nuages en alternance se
généralisera sur l'ensemble du pays
toutefois en fin d'après midi de
nouveaux nuages porteurs de pluie
aborderont la bretagne les températures
seront en légère baisse
faites attention dans la soirée les
routes risquent d'être glissantes à la
suite d'averses
un rappel pénible tout d'abord avec une
carte et les points où vous en êtes
temps voulu à l'aller vous avez souffert
ici sur l'autoroute a6 pris dans un
bouchon de 50 km entre paris porte
d'orléans et fleury en bière fulminé là
sur l'autoroute a10 à allen au nord
d'orléans ça n'en finissait plus quelle
tristesse impatiente et ici encore près
de montlhéry sur la rn 20 à la grange
aux cercles et à l'est du mans assaut
sur huisne vous n'avez pas été sage et
vous êtes trouvé pris dans les
embouteillages
vous avez dédaigné bison futé voici ce
qui vous est arrivé parce que vous êtes
partis massivement les parisiens surtout
et tous en même temps il est vrai que
les congés scolaires coïncidé cette
année avec le début de ce long week end
les conseillers t ne partez pas vendredi
soir ni samedi matin résultat c'était la
ruée et les voitures bloquées à présent
vous pensé au retour aux villes qui vous
attendent certaines assez abandonné
un nouveau plan de bataille est préparé
pour les retours massifs si vous voulez
rouler comme ça bien avoir une
circulation fluide respecter ces
quelques conseils
tout en étant prudent sur la route qui a
déjà fait 70 morts et 600 blessés
on
rentré mardi avant 15h pas le soir si
vous le pouvez prenez le mercredi matin
ça c'est l'idéal
il ne fera pas très beau sur la route il
pleut beaucoup ces temps ci et vous
allez trouver une grisaille mouillé mais
enfin bon courage quand même la fermeté
dans le dialogue c'est toute la
politique du gouvernement français dans
ces relations qui reste tout de même
tendu avec l'algérie au moment où ce
pays
dieu parce que ce pays couvre les
activités du front polisario depuis
vendredi soir depuis ce qu'on peut
considérer comme un conseil de guerre à
l'elysée avec les ministres concernés et
le chef d'état major des armées
la france dit une chose simple et une
chose qui doit sonner aux oreilles des
algériens et des sahraouis
nous ne pouvons pas admettre la
politique des otages et d'une part on
fait tout ce qu'on peut pour expliquer
que les français enlevés à zuera tu sont
des civils et qu'ils n'ont rien à voir
avec le conflit qui oppose le polisario
à la mres mauritanie et au maroc
il ya des milliers de français environ
250 milles qui travaillent un peu
partout à l'étranger accepter ce qui
s'est passé en mauritanie reviendrait à
accepter le risque de la prise d'otages
pour tous ne ressortissant où qu'ils
soient
d'autre part les otages de zuera tu
travaillais en territoire mauritanien un
territoire qui n'est pas contesté au
plan international si celui de l'ancien
sahara espagnol lait contesté par le
polisario
voilà pour le principe on ne peut pas
admettre que les civils soient enlevées
à l'occasion de coups de main et que
l'action humanitaire ensuite et tant de
mal à se développer
ne serait ce que pour avoir des
nouvelles des otages c'est ce que la
france tente d'expliquer à l'occasion de
ce qu'on appelle une intense activité
diplomatique pour laquelle monsieur de
guy ringot notre ministre des affaires
étrangères est continuellement à son
poste à paris hier soir vous le savez
notre ambassadeur à alger a remis au
président boumédiène un message de
monsieur giscard d'estaing la teneur de
ce message n'a pas été révélé mais il
tendait certainement à expliquer
l'attitude française de fermeté des
contacts ont lieu à genève entre la
france et la croix rouge internationale
un fonctionnaire du quai d'orsay
pourrait partir dès demain pour alger
mais on ne peut pas dire ce soir que la
diplomatie prennent le pas sur
l'avertissement nil inverse
ce qui est certain c'est que la france
se réserve en quatre
échec la possibilité d'une intervention
militaire pourquoi pas ne serait-ce que
pour que la mauritanie cesse d'être un
réservoir d'otages français depuis
samedi soir m me quel avocat des
familles des personnes disparues à
zhouqu et rate maîtres blum secrétaire
de la fédération internationale des
droits de l'homme sont à alger ils
attendent ils ont fait avec claude
bertrand notre envoyé spécial le bilan
de leurs contacts dans notre édition de
13 heures ce matin même j'ai eu un
contact direct par téléphone avec un
représentant du front polisario veut lui
ai transmis l'angoissent des familles il
m'a écouté n'a pas interrompu
il m'a indiqué qu'il transmettrait à qui
de droit
ma demande de rencontre j'attends la
réponse
mais j'entends garder espoir monsieur
boum c'est un premier pas de fait donc
vous retrouver l'espoir et plus
exactement je n'ai jamais perdu car cela
voudrait dire que je désespère dans les
trois clubs
brière spontanément le président de la
croix rouge sahraoui et j'assiste
spontanément m'a fixé rendez-vous
alors bien sûr nous avons discuté d'un
terrain qui nous est commun les droits
de l'homme
que vous at il dit il m'a d'abord exposé
les problèmes des droits de l'homme
concernant son peuple il m'a parlé de
sévices ma part le torturent des besoins
en médicaments que pouvaient avoir les
réfugiés et je lui affirmer comme
c'était bon de voir que nous allons
transmettre les dossiers qu'il m'a
donnée au président de la division des
droits de l'homme à l'onu
je lui dit également que notre
fédération l'écrire à monsieur kurt van
den pour qu'ils prescrivent une enquête
internationale mais bien sur les droits
de l'homme ne se divise pas et je lui ai
parlé du problème qui me préoccupait je
lui ai demandé des nouvelles des
personnes détenues alors il m'a fait la
réponse que je vais plus dire que j'ai
noté en lui disant que je la dirai je
vous la firme comme représentant du
croissant rouge sahraoui comme n'avons
aucune indication de la part des
autorités politiques ce qui amenait
immédiatement ma demande il faut donc de
jeu
adresse aux autorités compétentes il
faut donc absolument que je vois le
représentant des autorités et il s'est
engagé à transmettre ma demande j'ai
assisté il a précisé je transmettrai
votre demande immédiatement gérer ce pas
et je garde malgré quelques signaux très
relatif de détente internationale entre
le cambodge et le reste du monde par
exemple aujourd'hui les rumeurs selon
lesquelles les relations diplomatiques
avec l'urss et ses alliés pourraient
être rétablis par phnom penh malgré cela
et bien il ne se passe pas de jour sans
que se produise de graves incidents de
frontière entre les khmers rouges et la
population thaïlandaise une famille le
père la mère l'enfant ont été tués hier
soir lors de l'attaqué d'un hameau
proche du poste frontière d'aranha prat
est à 330 km 2 à l'est de bangkok
une école et une maisons ont été
incendiées au cours de cette attaque de
villages par les khmers rouges
c'est dans cette région que se trouvent
les camps de réfugiés ils sont
d'ailleurs directement sous le feu des
mortiers et des canons cambodgiens qui
n'a pas vu un camp de réfugiés où se
trouve comme c'est se retrouve comme
c'est le cas dans cette partie de l'asie
tous les exclus des régimes politiques
victorieux n'a pas idée de ce que peut
être la misère humaine pourtant il ya
des gens qui ne recule pas devant
l'horreur des gens qui sont là partout
partout où l'homme est broyé broyer
écrasé la mine et des gens qui ne
renonce pas des gens qui veulent soigner
soigner soigner encore là où d'autres
baisserait les bras
ces hommes vous les avez déjà vu hier
soir ce sont les médecins sans
frontières que leur importe la couleur
des régimes politiques et la couleur de
la peau des agonisants
ils y vont quand personne ne veut y
aller il était dans ces camps de
réfugiés en thaïlande où s'entassent
cambodgien et laotien voici leurs
témoignages recueillis par michel bader
il y à plus de 90 mille réfugiés en
thaïlande recensés actuellement il y en
a quelques dizaines de milliers qui ne
sont pas recensées
certains réfugiés arrivent du vietnam
qu'ils quittent par bateau ceux qui ont
de la chance arrive en thaïlande ceux
qui ont moins de chance arrive au
cambodge où ils sont exécutés et
d'autres sont rapidement à cours de
carburant et tombe en panne dans la mer
de chine où il dérive actuellement on
peut penser que deux à trois bateaux sur
4 cuil en mer de chine sans arriver en
taisant les cambodgiens traversent la
frontière qui était perméable au début
mais qui désormais est miné et
surveillée par les khmers rouges
hélas l'hécatombe est massive une arrive
environ une personne sur dix une
personne sur 15 actuellement qui
parvient à franchir la frontière
quelle est la vie en ce moment à
l'intérieur du cambodge il ya certains
qui ont été exécutés comme ça
radicalement les ans les militaires les
fonctionnaires les intégrales parce
qu'ils sont accusés de dany l'immeuble
comme on dit et si atteint autres
une façon peut-être plus landes on les
envoie dans les camps ou bien dans les
zones très malsaine compte des milliers
et des milliers qui ont été cassées mais
quid moi même aussi dans la zone des
canes amour très malsaine exemple pas le
disent très virulent et l'a
naturellement avec la famine
on vous donne pas assez à manger avec
des travaux fois ces jo et nuit je vous
prends jours on a faim on est malade par
le docteur par des médicaments
localement on va mourir mais d'une façon
assez lent les réfugiés laotiens les
montagnards et les laotiens parviennent
plus facilement à franchir la frontière
qui est constitué du mékong sur la
majeure partie de l'étendue de la
frontière et c'est eux qui forment le
groupe le plus nombreux d'environ 40000
à 50000 réfugiés alors je crois
l'acteur qu'il ya un problème
particulier au laos avec les hmong
exprime m'expliquer ce problème des
mains oui voilà des gens qui ont pas de
chance on peut dire un peu que c'était
cdt maudit c'est une peuplade maudite
pourquoi et bien parce que au laos y
passe pour anticommunistes en thaïlande
où senna c'est le même ethnie il passe
pour communiste savez que lorsque les
banques fuient la hausse pour revenir en
thaïlande
ils ont beau être anti communistes sont
pris pour des communistes et ils sont
considérés comme les gens suspecte pour
les réfugiés vous savez qu'il ya trois
solutions seulement ont trouvé un avenir
soit intégration en thaïlande soit
retour au pays d'origine et le soin leur
recherche d'une terre d'asile retour au
pays d'origine s'ils retournent au laos
et vont disparaître intégration ballon
je vous dis la suite
sion qui en thaïlande pour eux il ne
reste que la recherche d'une terre
d'asile
seuls deux pays au monde ne s'occupe de
leur trouver une terre d'asile
sérieusement je veux dire c'est la
france les états unis quand je dis
sérieusement il ya de bien d'autres pays
qui en prennent par ci par là je parle
baiser on en a pris 2,9
la suisse 1,8 enfin rien de rien de bien
sérieux
je voudrais bien qu'on sache que si ces
gens ne sortent pas des camps ils vont y
crever ils vont pourrir dans des camps
de réfugiés
donc les gens qui refusent une solution
pour les monde doivent savoir que et
qu'on a la mort par pourrissement
quarante mille personnes
voilà je pense que ce sos entre
guillemets se passe de tout commentaire
en revanche ce que vous attendez
certainement c'est l'adresse de ses
médecins sans frontières la voici 11 rue
crozatier 75012 paris
11 rue crozatier paris 12e médecins sans
frontières en politique française ça a
été le calme plat aujourd'hui on pouvait
s'y attendre mais comme la courte
semaine qui vient verra le premier
ministre s'attaque est certainement un
problème des prix parce que l''indice a
été trop fort en septembre 0,9 pour cent
on peut tout de même noter cette
déclaration d'andré bergeron plutôt
pessimiste dans une interview à la fp le
leader de force ouvrière qui rencontrera
raymond barre vendredi prochain
d'ailleurs et auquel il se plaindra sans
doute qu'on n'ait pas retenu son idée de
la cinquième semaine de congés payés une
idée qu'il n'abandonne pas andré
bergeron déclare que le second pari de
raymond barre sur l'inflation est en
passe d'échouer et il a l'intention de
dire au premier ministre que la part des
salaires dans le phénomène de
l'inflation n'est pas aussi importante
qu'on a bien voulu le faire croire
andré bergeron met en cause les
imperfections dans les circuits de
distribution responsable autant que la
hausse des prix des fruits et légumes
dans une large mesure dit-il de la
hausse des prix actuelle
quant à la cfdt tout en reconnaissant
que des difficultés réelles existent
actuellement sur le plan de la
mobilisation des travailleurs
pour l'action elle va tout de même
proposé à la cgt et à la fédération de
l'éducation nationale une action
unitaire de la plus large ampleur
possible dans les semaines qui viennent
une rencontre devrait avoir lieu cette
semaine avec la cgt
quand le vin est tiré il faut le boire
celui de l'année 77 ne sera pas
considéré comme une grande année les
vendanges qui sont presque terminés
affiche ce résultat général mais
n'oublions pas l'expression consacrée
chez les vignerons 77 sera une année
jalouse
ce qui signifie qu'elle sera mauvaise
pour les uns et bonne juste à côté
le moindre rayon de soleil aura eu son
importance pour ceux qui ont vendangé
tard l'arrière saison a sauvé bien des
grappes d'ailleurs dans le beaujolais on
a eu la sagesse d'attendre
et ce n'est que le 25 novembre que la
vente du beaujolais primeur sera permise
avec quinze jours de retard
un beaujolais déjà critiquée on lui
reproche comme à bien des vins
d'appellation d'être cette année un très
bon client pour les sucreries
jean françois robinet c'est une
tradition du mâconnais l'hommage à
benoît raclée qui sauva la vigne en
trouvant le moyen de traiter la pyrale
l'une des maladies les plus fatales
c'est aussi la première présentation des
vins nouveaux de mâcon et du beaujolais
à romanèche thorins le maire n'est pas
vignerons mais il s'est apprécié les
couilles
ils sont très forts sont pas la
vinification n'est pas terminée
justement non
sans pas le garder il a fallu je
préviens peut certainement
comme partout voix
c'est le point sensible les viticulteurs
n'aime pas beaucoup que l'on parle du
sucre âge qui corrige le manque de
soleil et permet de remonter le degré du
vin or cette année la météo n'a pas
toujours permis une bonne maturité pape
à celle avec des codes couleurs mais
cette année alors il faut dire que c'est
beau jurer s'élever ritter beaujard à la
rue une robe élégante tout est fine
entre deux chaises
beaucoup plus léger que l'année dernière
oui le vin et puis les jeunes une somme
pas l'arabe est plus légère sera pas une
grande grande année évidemment sera
peut-être pas l'année de l'année passée
mais enfin ce sera un pas qui ça très
bon taux acceptable et il faut bien
reconnaître quand on voit le résultat
la richesse alcoolique et quand même
beaucoup plus faible que l'an dernier ça
au résultat nous n'avons pas pu arriver
à ce que nous avions l'année dernière
c'est peut-être pas un mal d'ailleurs
parce que c'est vrai toujours se fera
dès d'un pull et j'ai malheureusement le
vin reste le plus souvent payés au degré
pour le négoce est un argument de vente
est une garantie pour la conservation
d'où la chaptalisation qui est
d'ailleurs une coutume dans le
beaujolais
c'est vrai parti de là la technologie
actuelle mise au point déjà depuis
ainsi plus d'un siècle et demi est
actuellement ça correspond à ce que les
gens attendent du beaujolais le
beaujolais à 21 milles hectares
la quantité de sucre légale a ajouté 200
kg à l'hectare
cette année en raison de la présentation
d'année les doigts qui était utilisé à
plein ça fait quatre mille tonnes soit
fait pour des trains entiers
interdit dans les côtes du rhône et dans
le midi le sucre âge est autorisée
partout ailleurs jusqu'à une certaine
limite qui permet de relever le vin de 2
degrés une pratique contestée car elles
augmentent aussi le volume de la récolte
déjà excédentaires sur le plan national
mais chacun considère évidemment son
propre problème parce que à votre avis
la chaptalisation abîme les uns n'ont
certainement pas d'auto - dans ce temps
qu'on nous restons dans une dans une
chaptalisation normal disons sérieuse
dire il ne faut pas exagérer pour
déséquilibrer le 20 mai cette année
précisément l'acidité plutôt soutenu
sans être exagérée du vin permet
précisément un apport de sucres un peu
supérieur à la normale si jamais vous
passez ce long week-end procès à
proximité des pommiers je vous le
souhaite
et vous vous rendrez compte que l'année
n'a pas été très bonnes non plus pour
les pommes on a beau récolter le peu
qu'on a on sait qu'il ne faut pas trop
compter les garder longtemps cet hiver
surtout si elles n'ont pas été traités
oui mais voilà traiter les arbres
fruitiers sait bien quelles que soient
les accidents de saison mais est ce que
ça ne représente pas un danger
tout le monde se pose largement la
question depuis quelques années mais
elle a été une façon très scientifique
récemment l'académie de médecine par
trois spécialistes pour l'information la
protection et la représentation des
consommateurs
on utilise actuellement environ 150
produits antiparasitaires à usage
agricole sur les fruits comme sur les
légumes avant la récolte
la réglementation est très stricte mais
il ya aussi le traitement après la
récolte avec d'autres produits et pour
les protéger pour protéger les fruits
contre les altérations or souvent et
c'est là le problème
la dose maximale de ces produits est
dépassé d'où les risques pour la santé
publique que j'évoquais pire bourget en
fait la loi autorise l'utilisation de 43
substances chimiques pour désinfecter ou
protéger les fruits et légumes contre
les altérations diverses mais il y en
ad'autres d'utilisation communes qui ne
figure pas dans la loi ainsi sur plus de
100 matières actives utilisées dans des
vergers de pommiers
seuls 22 d'entre elles
ont fait l'objet d'études précises or
les résidus de ces substances actives
peuvent être nocifs pour la santé
si les doses maximales admissibles sont
dépassés et des enquêtes menées en 74
ont montré que cela arrive parfois
notamment pour les agrumes et les
salades de serre chez ces dernières dans
62% des cas des échantillons soumises à
examen
la teneur en fongicides dépassent celles
considérées comme maximale pour l'homme
il n'est pas rare que ce taux réels soit
le tripou le quadrupède de celui
considéré comme le taux de tolérance ce
fait explique en particulier que des
salades et des pommes françaises ont été
refusées par des pays voisins
importateurs afin de remédier à cette
situation les techniciens alimentaires
ont demandé que les moyens de contrôles
soient renforcés et que soit diminuer le
nombre des produits chimiques toléré
d'autre part il souhaite que les
vendeurs et les utilisateurs soient
mieux informés de ces problèmes qui
mettent en cause l'innocuité des fruits
et des légumes consommés journellement
dans le pays
on souhaiterait que ce cri d'alarmé
poussé devant la cabine médecine fut
entendu avec vous je verrai gilbert les
autres nouvelles de ce journal
la monnaie anglaise d'abord la monnaie
anglaise n'arrête pas de monter la livre
à côté 1 dollars 84 sur le marché de
chez eux des changes de londres
aujourd'hui cela fait une hausse de près
de 4% 48 heures raison de ce bon les
britanniques ont décidé de laisser
flotter leur devise est de ne plus la
freiner fasse un dollar qui lui
s'affaiblit ce problème monétaire sera
sans doute évoqué au cours du prochain
sommet franco-britannique qui doit
réunir à londres le président giscard
d'estaing et le premier ministre
britannique james callahan les 12 et 13
décembre ces dates ayant été précisé
aujourd'hui à l'hélice en visite privée
en france le président tchadien malloum
à déjeuner à l'elysée il y à quelques
temps monsieur malloum avait reçu une
aide matérielle de la france pour lutter
contre les rebelles du tibesti ceux là
même qui détenait madame clos str et on
pense que monsieur malloum a demandé
aujourd'hui le renouvellement de cette
assistance
la province du tibesti échappant
toujours au contrôle du gouvernement
tchadien
le premier ministre du québec rené
lévesque sera lui en visite officielle à
paris à partir de mercredi des jeunes
avec valéry giscard d'estaing elle sera
reçue également à l'assemblée nationale
sauf fast ces honneurs inquiète le
gouvernement canadien
rené lévesque ont ses partisans d'une
certaine autonomie des canadiens
francophones et pour le chef du
gouvernement fédéral pierre trudeau
monsieur lévesque doit être traité comme
un simple premier ministre d'une
province canadienne
réponse de xavier deniau vice président
de l'assemblée nationale française
dans le passé les premiers ministres
québécois ont toujours été reçue ainsi
et c'est donc une longue tradition 20
tonnes de choux fleurs encore jetés aux
ordures ce matin à châteaurenard la
production est trop forte pour le marché
ne trouve pas preneur
en tout cas entoure une semaine en une
semaine on aura détruit ainsi près de
500 tonnes de choux fleurs dans le
vaucluse
vous le voyez c'est problème inverse de
celui du raisin et des pommes que nous
évoquions tout à l'heure la grève des
hôtesses et des stewards sur la france
demain affectera surtout les vols moyen
courriers dans ce secteur de liaison sur
trois seront supprimés en revanche pas
de perturbations prévues sur les lignes
sur les longs courriers
le syndicat national des personnels
commerciaux qui a décidé cet arrêt de
travail a décidé cet arrêt de travail
parce que la compagnie nationale veut
réduire le nombre des hôtesses et des
stewards sur certains vols 747 dans
plusieurs écoles maternelles du
finistère les maîtres ne s'adresseront
aux enfants conte breton depuis quelques
mois l'établissement bretonnants
pourrait-on dire fonctionne à lampaul
ploudalmézeau près de quimper et on va
en ouvrir d'autres à brest rennes
lannion et or et c'est une vieille
revendication des champions du de la
culture et de l'identité bretonne qui
sera satisfaite
l'objectif étant pour eux de permettre
aux bretons qui le désirent de pratiquer
leurs langues comme le français et
d'être ainsi parfaitement bilingue
fausse manoeuvre lourde de conséquences
à la gare de triage de villeneuve saint
georges près de paris un jeune apprenti
conducteur de la sncf qui se trouvait
aux commandes d'un convoi de
marchandises à leur territoire comme
vous le voyez sa locomotive a déraillé
elle s'est plantée sur la voie a causé
beaucoup de dégâts aux installations
quant au conducteur malheureux il a eu
l'oeil arraché un oeil arraché dans cet
accident
on a trouvé toute autre chose on a
trouvé un colis bien embarrassants sur
la place du marché à meulan dans les
yvelines influent métallique entouré de
béton qui contiendrait des déchets
radioactifs apparemment les radiations
émises par ces déchets sont extrêmement
faibles peut être même nue
mais avant de se prononcer il faut tout
de même faire analyser le contenu par
des spécialistes de saclay le plus
étonnant dans cette affaire c'est que
pour l'instant on ne sait pas encore à
qui appartiendrait ces déchets
radioactifs 14 de chevaux au départ du
prix maurice gillois steeple-chase de
4400 mètres choisi comme support pour le
tiercé de la toussaint demain à auteuil
parmi les favoris d'andré theron on
trouve le 8 le 4 le 1 le 10 le 6 et le
14 dernières informations il s'agit très
exceptionnellement d'un message
personnel mais il y va peut-être de la
vie d'un enfant ce matin un pharmacien
de forcalquier a vendu un flacon de
sérum physiologique vraisemblablement
destiné un bébé mais il ya eu une erreur
sur le contenu il s'agit d'un produit
toxique
la personne qui a acheté ce flacon est
prié de se mettre en rapport de toute
urgence avec le centre antipoison de
marseille dont le numéro de téléphone et
75 25 25
j'aurais fait 75 25 25
la gymnastique a fait encore ces jours
ci le bonheur de la télévision et cela à
l'occasion de la coupe du monde qui
s'est déroulé à oviedo en espagne on
risque d'en retenir surtout ce festival
des supers minettes de l'école
soviétique
aujourd'hui c'est l'enfant gymnastes qui
est rennes avec ses acrobaties ses
fantaisies et ses minauderies il y a
quelque chose d'un peu gênant tout de
même dans ce compte dont ce concours
d'enfant prodige est la reine de
montréal nadia comaneci n'était pas là
elle elle avait 15 ans au moment des
jeux et il en a maintenant c'est et demi
elle a changé c'est une jeune fille et
c'est la raison pour laquelle on peut le
penser
elle ne s'est pas présenté à cette coupe
du monde elle a modifié son programme et
les spécialistes pensent qu'elle nous
réserve quelques surprises à strasbourg
l'an prochain pour les championnats du
monde
en attendant c'est bien l'école
soviétique qui a dominé la coupe
d'oviedo mais il n'y avait pas que des
filles
pierre fut là nous présente les deux
grands vainqueurs de la compétition
nikolai andrianov 25 ans champion
olympique
l'image de la perfection gymnastique
c'est aussi le reflet de l'école
soviétique où la réussite ne s'obtient
que par le travail à nos que l'on oublie
souvent lorsque l'extraordinaire revient
à chaque seconde pour acquérir une telle
maîtrise et donner une si grande
impression de fluidité andriano pas
répétée plus de 2000 fois ses preuves
sorti le talent et l'imagination en
perez et puis le petit prodige maria
filato va hein mais 38 33 kg déjà 15 ans
ambitieuse et combative lancé par les
soviétiques qui ont compris qu'elles
pouvoir de séduction pouvait avoir
auprès du public et gymnastes poupée
tout cela pour concurrencer justement
nadia comaneci avec filato va c'est vrai
la gymnastique a pris une nouvelle
dimension où seuls les enfants acrobates
réussite mais on freni déjà à l'idée que
ce sport féminin si merveilleux devienne
un jour les jeux lucien
oui ça aurait veut rien à la performance
mais enfin je crois que c'est la
réflexion qu'il faut se faire ce soir
bonne soirée à tous au nom de toute
l'équipe de tf1 actualité dernier
journal jacques le noir vers 23h20 merci